honestly
thank you
let's say and the chief executive
Jonathan Stevenson
a good evening ladies and gentlemen it's
lovely to be with you this evening I do
hope that you have had a really good
summer and you are with roaring ready to
get stuck back into Council business
as always we're going to begin our time
by prayer so if you wouldn't mind uh
whether you believe in it or not could I
just ask that you bow your heads as we
pray
almighty God we bring before you the
agenda for tonight's meeting
that we who have been entrusted with the
responsibility to govern and make
decisions for those who have elected us
be guided by the best of motives and
with the interests of all for the
benefit of all
Lord give us clear minds and the desire
to hear all quotes of you including
those who may be diametrically opposed
to our own
and for an openness of Demands
make us gracious and courteous to friend
and opponent alike with a real sense of
working together for this district and
the areas that are represented by each
of our district councils
at the same time we commend for your
blessing the work of all the employees
of Rochford District Council who
maintain Implement and make possible the
words that are debated discussed and
formed into policy
we pray this in Jesus name
amen
did you know the words and would like to
join in I invite you now to join with me
the prayer that Jesus taught us the
words the family prayer
Our Father which art in heaven Hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on Earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil for
thine is the kingdom the power and the
glory forever and ever amen
so that God and hold you in his love
fill you with his peace and leave you in
his hope
and the blessing of God Almighty the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit be
with each one of you gathered here today
and all of those whom you love this day
and for everyone
amen
decision
foreign
[Music]
given the size of this room and the
numbers are present cannot please ask
that you put your hand up clearly five
year so that none of it can be so that
so yeah it can be easier soon I always
the normal rules have been made applied
no membership speech before the five
weeks if can I please ask you not to
repeat anything previously
will have given an opportunity to speak
worse
foreign
[Music]
consultation
very much anymore
[Music]
thank you
hi item two a gender item by item two uh
forecast
this evening this question is directly
relevant to write them not
this question after item seven
please have a second
do you how you wanting to bring it for
this
one are the only decorations of Interest
[Music]
Ed
um
good enough
[Music]
thank you
so
the next time I was gender writing for
announcements from the chair chairman
Lee not the head of pay services
but we missed one so I rather than avoid
it by sitting here and wrapping up all
these things I attended 17 uh functions
or appearances it's an Afghan meeting
and uh and I must admit I enjoyed every
one of them some schools some charity
sanctions and so on and if you're happy
with that stuff
thank you Council donations
thank you
very gentlemen
thank you foreign
[Music]
you're good
the general item six report and Urgent
decisions they were on that
item seven
you know immunology and Event Center on
an environment Mississippi
thank you
[Music]
because thank you
members thank you for regional
development in advance of the community
we are aware of the recent history of
facility and his wife
because legislative
[Music]
and a great job for your activities
pretty good
[Music]
an executive meeting has on the 7th of
March this year agree that the future
models of America Center should be
chronic on it and it looks forward to
full Council for discussion
you know
and it's reports there are seven
recommendations before you and I'm
seeking your support for each of that
you can order to Development Center For
Less Community exercise
Council to provide the most expensive
facility possible
is here to support the Arts and events
sector and with this Refreshments
controversial roses
going forward
thereby inducing professional functional
finances
including this is
environmentally sustainable when
possible
foreign
[Music]
very much
you now need to focus on a commercial
competitive offering and to recognize
the change in operating models
originally proposed
the campaigns
and have an activity to support an
understanding from the interest and the
commercial rather than making interview
change
this will enable us to negotiate to
commercial bases and there's no upcoming
investment in the cafe
now as a report state
foreign
ize the building
use
[Music]
foreign
okay
I would like to move the motion that the
recommendations are approved
remember
thank you very much I actually wanted to
move
to millennials
for these Notions I want to go up to to
do that in regards to the first R1 I
believe it's been here
um the primary function realistically
of what happened in the past is the
biggest act as for the community
and I would like to alter if I know I'm
ready
item a
to read where we had the real arts and
Event Center family functions of
corporate arts and event sector I would
like to amended that it is said
that it should be the real art community
and events center I think Community
needs to be at the center
of what this is all about and I believe
that's fairly important as far as that's
concerned
um in regards to Item B
to change the word where it's got that
the food and drink are free at the
Melbourne Arts Center supports the
events and is a commercial relative
offering uh changed the world degree
to any
one that any food and drink offered a
new art and it should be obviously
community and arts except for arts and
Community Center please
and I can see
again changing what it says there to
Renewal Arts community and Event Center
and if you see exactly the same
so it ensures
community and Event Center is
environmentally stable those are related
I think just
given that uh page 7.6 and that's 3.5
is equals by four we like to be searched
understanding the demand for services
and looking at other potential uses for
the site the same temperature and
possibly advanced emotion
[Music]
difficult points to the very original
plan for what would happen
under the agency finally
the real voice registered as an asset of
community value to your community is
very important and that that's why I
want to interpret it to ensure that
instead something that was supported by
radical Council hence why wishing to put
that in public operations with that in
mind it's like sensory improved
communities in its life
here with the various prices so those
are from the community so that is
my commitments
[Music]
benefits
right it will hurt the suggested
amendments it's anybody anything
thank you chairman
um as as my colleague um said looking
back over a lot of the bookings in
recent months um
September a vast number of them have
been community
with smaller activities
and the original motion that States
primary function to the Arts and events
maybe concerning with the report that
that could exclude the community aspect
I think that would be the sort of a
sentiment if you're adding the word
community in there so how can you
support that suggestion and it grows up
to what radio Town Council did in terms
of the beauty asset
um Community because that wanted to say
the important for those people some of
those people at least so I support
Council
National Institution
[Music]
nicely sorry I'm looking at right let's
put reading the attitude
okay
proposal and the seventh mile
and the thing of the instruction
was
to operate the new arts and Event Center
so now with the proposals come forward
try not to change their own proposal
if the community is not excluded we
could put the title will be 10 words in
it but the main attraction of the bill
for is an art and event center and that
is for the community was rare so I do
not support the amendment
foreign
[Music]
for everyone
encompassing everyone which is hopefully
what the market research
these recommendations are approved will
actually make the point we see what is
the meaning policies
I don't want these I think I just felt
this is really important that arts and
events is a nice coverall we're not
excluding anybody thank the chair
thank you well I think
I'll make this the last one I missed a
lot because we can we can all make a
judgment when we have the value so we
just want to say briefly thank you very
much indeed Mr chairman um look I listen
to what counselor Robert Wilson has said
and she doesn't want to say anything uh
to to uh exclude a word Community I
would say why not put it in it doesn't
seem to be a big issue from the other
side so uh why can't we just put it in
for the sake of clarity through our
community
um and I think with the reference to
what was said in the executive in March
I think that was the generic name that
we will answer the Event Center is noted
but here we're talking about about
specific uses and I think it's right to
Encompass the community and explore the
sense right across the Rockford District
thank you Mr chairman thank you we're
gonna take a vote on this thing
um so it's on the amendment I've said
enough there so excuse me you haven't
heard what I want to say look you're
only are you going to repeat what
everybody else has said
what I'd like to say is can we have a
recorded vote please well there needs to
be a certain percentage of your party
tonight so if you don't want to
understand that
[Music]
thank you Memphis would you please
um vote against the amended promotion
when your name is Court
council Mrs Belton
councilor please
so what point of order sorry are we
taking recommendation on dock here or
are we taking recommendation hey
the amendment over the amendment was
thank you still cool
again can counselor mrsborough
passengers butcher
or councilor Carter or Council account
School
foreign
Council across again
counselor AIDS against
me
Council James today
[Music]
yeah it's a night
that's a landfall okay salon
again
councilor Elliot Mason
councilor John Mason
Council isn't that person
councilor James Newport
Council Lisa Newport
news
against cats are Sharp council is sure
[Music]
Council Casa spearing
cousins Squires program against Council
Stanley
that's a step toe for cancer world or
cats love Williams
against
[Music]
Joe Wilson
against councilor Simon Middleton
are there any obsessions
now
thank you chair that is 11 4 25 against
that motion is lost
head members will now go back to the
original where
and suggestion or motion and as we voted
this on block I intend to take the other
remainder on block so okay
and you can clarify that please chairman
is this just recommendations one of the
four items and not all of the weapons
it's the four items we just know I'm not
going to go any further than that we'll
discuss that further up along thank you
so we're going to take an envelope floor
at the floor
[Music]
you want to record everything
then we'll take a record
sorry chairman to delay a long meeting
that we've likely taken separately we're
not happy for them to be taken on blog
the counselor Wilbur you want to do it
you're happy to take it all on an
amendment
why why are you so against it
individually now Roger want to put this
one out
process
and we won't
[Music]
Shannon I think just for a point of
clarification for them is I think what
you were suggesting is that you take
recommendation one with the four
elements of recommendation one on block
first we will vote on that and then
we'll move to the beginning six
recommendations afterwards at which one
members will be able to speak to those
remaining six recommendations
foreign
over there
thank you members and please can you
decide before against the motion when
your name is called and this is for
recommendations one to seven okay on
blog okay this is uh Belton
no no
I'm sorry right so okay
recommendation one
abstaining for the reason just explained
okay councilor booth people
council Mrs Brewer
councilman Mrs butcher
councilman Carter
cats are constable
good Stein has the cribs
cancel across
four Council FD
Stone
okay so Eaves
Mrs Gregson
Stone
good evening
Council membership or Castle play
councilor night
that's a Lambo
cancer annoying
Newcastle Linden
well
Catherine this is Mason
Professor Elliot later
the councilor John Mason
the person
Professor James Newport Council Lisa
Newport councilor Mrs page
councilor sharp four councilman
[Music]
steering
custom describes Coleman
has his family or Council Steptoe
Council award
okay sir Williams
then
I got some with him
[Music]
okay
thank you chairman that's 24 for one
against
12 extensions that is okay
thank you
just finished with that we're now open
everybody Origins R2 to R7 that's all
the most suggested so anybody wanted it
cancer spirit
thank you Kevin I'd like to speak in
relation to our recommendation to
um
a couple of points I'd like to mention
I'd like to add to the motion with no
Financial liability to either party or
RDC at the end of the Present written
statement
I would also like to highlight chairman
of the reading
87.5
3.35 to 3.37
it appears that decisions have already
been made before this meeting
can the lead officer or the director
confirm that either that is correct and
that no little communication has been
forwarded to either of the partners in
this process if there has what is the
feedback from the two classes that have
been working with us for so long thank
you so much
okay
[Music]
um
being notified unfortunately doing is
doing something that I was able to meet
with the partners face to face so I
suppose when it's been act like the
purposes after coming tonight
[Music]
I mean
I'll go back to the first half that
there'll be no Financial commitment
either those parties
across the district council and secondly
I'm sorry but it seems to make a pass of
why this looks down on your gender if
the decision is already been like I
think that's totally wrong that's why we
have a full Council chairman thank you
thank you
thank you Joe
um thank you guys it's very I've
actually personally spoken to both those
organizations and spoke through the
process obviously disappointed subject
to council which is a good way tonight
but um
[Music]
in order
so I'm a bit confused sorry I'm a bit
confused has a decision being made to
anyone's the partnership or not because
the way the report reads is as though
they're being informed and we are no
longer they are no longer a preferred
partner that we're in that relationship
but then again we're sort of saying
to me
the way I'm dancing is they've already
been notified that we are they no longer
working with us
is that not true
as the council looks to propose many
decisions at Council meetings I just
expect early but as for good
communication we obviously want to reach
out to the organization group of names
in the report
um saying it's subject to account
decision there's a recommendation in the
report that suggests that AI principle
in if there is the case obviously would
like to have further downl
those Partners in this room as well
don't have that conversation groups and
I'm not going to speak but I've spoken
to you personally and made it clear that
the subject to accounts decision making
as well those currency that we do reach
out to their people before they see this
in the paper and published online
thank you
um so I'm speaking to the amendment the
councilor it's very important
correct about
our second date that's okay and so what
I wanted Clarity on so I understand
um Communications for that reason but
I've got a couple of concerns it doesn't
state if there's going to be any
financially patients here we already
know both Partners have financial
implications in the money that they've
spent to date they've made that point
clear they've made that point at RNs but
one of the partners said that would be
looking for compensation should it be
cut short so I think it's really risky
and difficult for us to agree emotion
when we don't know what the implications
could be for this council at this so
that concerns me the other concern is we
talked about later on in report going to
stock marketing for the cafe for
commercial reasons have no problem with
that and however had we could
communicated with one of the partners
who's interested in the fact that other
operating models have we discussed that
before we go back out to Market so again
it feels like a difficult motion to
support because we don't know the
feedback of the partners we don't know
the potential financial implications and
if that's again runs into tens of
thousands of pounds and that might make
it sort of deeply differently so just a
bit more clarity
situation
I mean I don't have the papers for the
POI
vehicles in July uh
made a decision by the executive
um maybe officers have been helped maybe
maybe bonds can help was there any offer
in the orientification in the EI process
that there would be any financial
implications in any party yes I know
foreign